- We're gonna wrap this hour up
with one last feel-good story,
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
Our final guest of the
day basically grew up
as one of the stars of the
FX series "Better Things."
When she started the show,
she was actually just nine.
Now, as the show heads into
its fifth, final season,
she's reflecting back and looking forward,
so everybody say hello to Olivia Edward!
(audience claps)
Hi Olivia!
- Hi.
- Oh my gosh, so how are you feeling
going into the final season?
You started the show so young.
- Yeah, I mean, it feels really
really bittersweet just
because of how much
of a huge part this show
has been in my life.
I mean, I started when I was
like eight or nine, I'm 15 now.
But I feel very grateful
to have been able to work
with the entire cast and
crew, especially Pamela Adlon
who not just stars, but
also writes, directs,
and produces the entire show.
She's incredible.
I mean, I'm going to be
forever grateful for her,
just for teaching me
everything, not just in acting,
but also in directing and writing.
So I'm really excited to,
like the characters do
this season, move forward,
make big decisions about
what I wanna do,
and take everything that
I've learned with me.
- I love that.
(audience cheers)
I love that experience
too, as a young woman
having other women so
supportive around you.
That's really cool.
I'm glad you got that right off the bat.
I have to say this
'cause your dad is psychic
medium John Edwards.
So were you able to get away
with anything as a teenager?
Oh, you're still a teenager.
Are you able to get away
with anything?
(audience laughs)
- No, I'm not.
And honestly, it doesn't even have to be
like a sneaky thing,
like it can be like a nice thing.
I tried surprising him with you know,
like a birthday gift.
I put it in his closet
until it was time to take it out.
And then he comes home,
automatically starts
like asking me questions.
He's like, "Hey, did you
put something in my closet?"
Hasn't been in there yet.
And I'm like, "No, why would I,
no, don't go in the closet.
" But it's like, you know,
I can't do any of that stuff.
- I love that you have this
relationship with your dad.
That's so cool.
Not everybody has it.
That's so special.
I'm so happy for you.
Especially the women, like I said,
that are so supportive
early on in your career.
I can't wait to see what you do.
I mean, you started at
nine you're only 15.
(audience clapping)
So, congratulations and thanks,
Olivia, for hanging with us
I'm liking your post right now, alright?
(audience cheers)
All right, everybody catch new
episodes of "Better Things"
Monday nights at 10
Eastern and Pacific on FX
and streaming on Hulu.
So usually at this point,
we'd give our guest money
on behalf of Pilot pen,
makers of "Frixion,"
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But today, that thousand dollars is going
to someone in the audience.
So, look under your chairs!
(audience cheering)
Look under your chairs!
Who's got it?
Somebody's got it under your chair.
We've never had an audience
that...There you go! There you go!
(audience cheers)
So wait, what's your name?
Where are you from?
- My name is
Sandra from San Diego.
- Sandra from San Diego, San Di-ah-go.
I love it.
What are you gonna do
with your money you think?
- Well, it's my friend
Sharon's birthday today.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So,
she was really excited to come see you.
So now I could take
her to lunch too, girl!
- [Kelly] Exactly! Exactly!
(audience cheers)
Well thank y'all for coming!
- Thank you so much!
- [Kelly] Have a good lunch!
- [Sandra] Thank you!